Welcome to this workshop on text to
speech model fine-tuning. I'm Ronan of
the Trellis Research YouTube channel and
today I'll be walking you through data
preparation and fine-tuning of Sesame's
CSM 1B model. You should be able to
follow along. All of the materials are
available on the Trellis research
GitHub. If you go to AI
Worldsfare-2025, you'll be able to find
the collab notebook and also the slides
that I'm going to go through for this
workshop. Now, by the end of this
workshop, you should be able to train a
texttospech model so that it sounds like
a specific voice. You should be able uh
to understand how token-based
texttospech models work. The one we're
going to train today is Sesame CSM1B,
but Orpheus from Canopy Labs is also a
tokenbased texttospech
model. We'll go through how to create a
voice data set. You can record one
yourself. Uh but today we're just going
to pull audio from a YouTube video. You
can pick which video and use that as a
basis for the finetuning. We'll cover
then fine-tuning using Unsloth, which is
a library based around transformers.
Many of you might be familiar with it.
And last fall, we'll evaluate
performance uh both before the
finetuning and after the finetuning. Now
before I start to get into the collab
notebook, it's just going to be one
collab note book that covers all of
these steps. I want to describe a little
bit how these models work very briefly.
If you do want to understand in much
more detail, uh I'll point you to a much
longer video about an hour and 30
minutes where I talk about token-based
uh texttospech models. I also talk a
little bit about Moshi. I'll put a link
to this in the GitHub repo as well. It
helps to start off with reviewing how a
tokenbased text model works such as say
the chat GPT models uh from OpenAI uh
like GPT40 or LMA series of models.
Those models which you'll be familiar
with most likely involve taking in a
string of text and predicting the next
uh word or token and then passing that
around so that you recursively predict
the next word. Now, when we talk about
text to speech, what we want to do is
take in a series of text tokens and
predict the next audio token. If you can
bear with me as to what an audio token
might be. And in fact, we'd like to be
able to pass in a history of text and
also audio from the earlier conversation
and then decode recursively. We'd like
to produce the next audio token. So, we
have a string of audio tokens that
represent the output speech uh that we
want. So, conceptually, this is what
we're trying to do. We need a
transformer model that instead of taking
in only text and outputting text tokens
can input ideally text and audio and
output a string of audio tokens. So the
question the first question then is how
do you make tokens for audio? How do you
take a wave a soundwave like this and
represent it uh in terms of discrete
tokens rather than continuous uh
frequencies or sound waves? And the
answer is you can represent audio or a
little piece of audio as a choice from a
code book. A codebook is like a
dictionary and inside the dictionary
there are a series of vectors where a
vector represents a given uh sound. Now
these code books could be fairly large
in order to represent a wide variety of
sounds and that could be the acoustics
and also the semantics. But it is
possible to take sound and represent it
in a discrete way much like text uh
represents meaning in a discrete
way. The way that these code books are
trained, I won't get into too much
detail, but broadly speaking, you need
to train um an encoder decoder where you
take a soundwave. You then have some
kind of transformer that converts it
into tokens and then you have another
transformer that will decode it back uh
into a wave. And the question you ask
during training is whether the output
here after encoding it to tokens and
decoding it back you ask the question of
whether it matches the input and to the
extent it doesn't match you will use
that difference or the loss to back
propagate and update these weights here.
So it is possible giving sufficient data
on sound waves to then train uh a code
book so you can represent those uh that
sound in a discrete form. Now it turns
out if you use that approach uh you can
represent sound using a code book but it
turns out insufficient to just have one
token for each time step. Actually what
works out better is to have a
hierarchical representation or at least
have multiple tokens allowed at the same
kind of time stamp or same window so
that you can have a more detailed
representation. So this is the idea
that's used in most tokenbased audio
models. Instead of just having one token
at each window, you will have multiple
tokens potentially set up in a hierarchy
so you represent higher level kind of
meaning or acoustics and then you have
more granular more granular and so you
have these multiple layers of
representation. Now there are a few ways
to set things up to have different
tokens represent sound at a given
window. The one we're going to focus on
is the sesame model uh where there are
32 tokens at every uh window that will
represent the sound. There is a zeroth
token that will be predicted by the main
transformer here, but then there's a
secondary transformer that's being used
to decode out the other 31 uh tokens of
meaning. So whereas here we basically
have sesame decoding out with a main
transformer auto reggressively these
first zeroth tokens the kind of stack
tokens are being decoded by a second
transformer. So actually Sesame has two
models. It's the main 1 billion
parameter model and then a much smaller
model that will decode out kind of these
hierarchical tokens here. So this is a
quick overview of how the model is going
to work. We will start off with a
pre-trained model that is capable of
taking in text and audio and outputting
uh a stream of audio here. And we'll see
how it performs. Just when we give it
some text, we'll see it generate or
we'll hear it generate some sound. But
then we're going to take a data set and
it's uh in my case it's going to be of
one of my YouTube videos with my voice
and we're going to see if we can make
the model sound a little bit more like
me by fine-tuning it uh on that data. So
with that we will move over to the
collab notebook. As I said you can find
it uh on trellis research if you look
for the AI worlds fair 2025 repo. And if
you open that up in Collab, you should
be able to run it for free using uh a
T5. So when you open up the
notebook, make sure that uh you are
connected to a GPU. This should be
available for free. If you're not
connected to a GPU, uh you can say
change runtime type and then you'll want
to select uh the TPU here. So I am
connected and there are two sections in
this notebook. If you're following
along, you can just open it up in your
browser. Now, there are two sections
we'll go through. The first is data
generation where we're going to pick a
YouTube video. We're going to use
Whisper in the Collab Notebook to
transcribe the YouTube video and then
we're going to convert it into a data
set. The data set will have audio
snippets of up to 30 seconds and they
will have text which will be the
transcription uh using
Whisper. Given that data set of
snippets, I think I will have maybe
around let's see 41 rows of data which
is actually enough to have an effect on
the quality. I have previously done
trainings with maybe shorter snippets of
only 10 seconds and 20 20 of those and I
don't think that's enough data. So I
would say if you've got 30 second
snippets probably having roughly 50 of
them is enough to start to have an
effect. And given that data set, we'll
then fine-tune the unsloth model or
sorry, we'll fine-tune the CSM model,
the SESB model using Unsloth, and we
will measure performance at the end and
see how that
fares. So, let's start off with the data
generation. And you can pick your own
YouTube video if you like. I recommend
picking a video where you just have one
speaker. You could pick a video with two
speakers, but you need to do more data
processing. you need to do diorization
to split that uh audio up into multiple
speakers which is not supported in this
basic notebook here. So I recommend
taking a video where you just have one
speaker. This is a a trellis video here.
You can then pick the model size the
whisper model size that you want to use
for
transcription. I recommend using turbo
which is almost as good as large. Um I
think it's better than definitely small
base and tiny but it's actually a lot
faster than large. So we'll go with
turbo.
run the installs. So, you'll need white
uh YouTube DLP. Note that this works
well in Collab. If you try and run this
notebook outside of Collab, you can run
into authentication issues where you'll
get blocked from downloading from
YouTube. So, I recommend running this in
Collab. Um you also need to install
Whisper, which is uh from OpenAI. And
with all of that installed, you should
be ready to then load the Whisper model
here and run the transcription.
And we're going to use the GPU. So we'll
use CUDA here. And it should then save
your transcript to a file to a JSON file
which will be saved here locally. So
what you should find is a JSON file uh
that's saved. And uh you should be ready
to to then use that file as a basis for
the training. Now when you run the
transcription, I'm not going to run it
here cuz it's uh going to take a little
bit of time. And when you have that JSON
file, um, you can take a look at that
file, which I'll show you now. Okay. So,
I've opened up the JSON file, and it has
a bunch of text and also details around
the exact tokens. It also will have the
segments of uh the
transcription. And what I recommend
doing is just take a quick read through
it. I know you won't be able to see
because of the font size here, but take
a look through for any words that you
think might be misspelled. And what you
can do is a quick find replace on some
of those variables. So for example,
often uh I'll see the word trellis with
two L's because that's how the correct
English word is spelled, but the word uh
trellis for the name of Trellis research
is one L. And so I'll often just do a
find replace uh for trellis and put in
tris and then I'll replace that
throughout. Now I've already done that,
so it's uh completed. But if you want to
make those fixes, what you can do is do
the find replace and then re-upload the
file to Google Collab. Just re upload it
here uh so that you can read it in and
use that corrected transcript then as
the basis for your fine-tuning data set.
So, at this point, what we've done is
we've grabbed the audio from YouTube. We
have transcribed it. We've corrected it
then
manually, and we're ready now to split
what's a long uh transcript consisting
of short segments from Whisper. And what
we want to do is combine some of those
segments so that we have longer chunks
up to about 30 seconds in length. Uh
we're going to use the sil simple
algorithm. We're simply going to stack
them until they reach more than 30
seconds and then we'll move to creating
a new row of data. So what we ultimately
want is rows of data that are max 30
seconds in length. So that's what we're
going to do here. I'm going to just log
into hugging face so that I can push a
data set up to hugging face. Now I've
done this earlier so I'm not going to uh
log in right now. I'm going to define
the organization. So if you've created
an account you can create an
organization minus con trellis. I'll
create a you a repo name and I'll create
the maximum length I want for the rows
of
data. Then I will grab the source audio
which should be saved from running the
YouTube extraction earlier and I'll also
specify the path to my JSON file which
could be an updated JSON file with those
corrections.
Then I'll load that JSON file and I'm
now going to run through basically
taking the segments here and adding them
together until we get to the maximum
duration. And when we're at the maximum
duration, we'll call that a row of data
and we'll move then uh to the next data
set. So with that done, as you can see
uh here, I've generated 41 clips. Uh
I've pushed it up to YouTube if you or
sorry pushed it up to Hingface. If you
don't want to push it up, just set this
to false. And yeah, my data set should
now be
available. So, if you're following
along, it will take a bit of time. You
might need to pause the video because
you need to run the transcription.
Should take a few minutes at most, even
if you have like half an hour or an hour
worth of video. And then you should find
your data set up here. And you can see
my snippets of text. And then you can
see the sound. So, I could uh, for
example, play some of these sounds and
test them out.
Now this is kind of a basic
implementation what I'm showing but you
can see already an opportunity for
improvement
here. Right now I'm adding segments of
text but I'm not being careful as to
whether the segments are ending. It
would be better if I ended every row of
data here on a full stop. That could be
done by using a library such as
NLTK to detect sentence boundaries or
you could even use just a regular
expression. So there is room for
improvement of how these data sets are
being compiled. Shouldn't make a huge
difference, but generally you want to
have kind of paragraphs that are
complete within a row of data here. All
right. So at this point, hopefully you
have your data set uh pushed up and
you've noted what your org name and your
data set name is. So we're ready to move
on uh to
fine-tuning. Now the first thing for
fine-tuning is to install Unsloth. Uh so
I've actually run this and I have run it
just uh earlier this morning. So we're
going to be able to follow on with these
cells. We're installing um Unsloth here
which includes transformers and a number
of packages for loading and fine-tuning
models. Next with Unsloth installed,
we're going to load the base model that
we want to train which is CSM1B. This is
the Sesame model. We're going to load it
with a maximum sequence length. This is
the maximum text text length which is
probably quite a bit longer than 30
seconds uh which it should be. We will
leave the data type as none. Yeah, the
data type if I'm on a T4 will be uh
float 16. So it'll be float
uh torch.flat 16 on T4 and it'll be uh
torch.bflat
16 on um anything more recent than that.
So on hopper or blackwell
GPUs also ampere as well. The auto model
is CSM for conditional generation. So
sesame models are now supported by
transformers and that's what onslaught
is leveraging here. You could quantize
the base model but it's not necessary
cuz CSM1B is just a few gigabytes in
size and the T4 is 15 GB. So it will fit
easily uh within this here. So the model
is going to download and it will then be
loaded into the GPU. When the shards are
loading, you should see that uh the GPU
should start to get full with the
shards. Now, this here looks like my GPU
usage is kind of high. It might suggest
I've loaded the model twice. Uh so, I
may have to restart my runtime and
reload it again. Uh but we'll see. It's
It's lowering down now, so maybe that's
okay. And what you can do then is print
out the model architecture just to take
a look. And yeah, there's quite a lot in
the CSM model.
There's the backbone model. This is the
main transformer model here. And then
there's the depth decoder. So this is
where you're decoding out those 31 other
tokens. And then there's also the model
that allows you to convert from the
waveform into tokens and tokens back to
the waveform. So you've got the codec
model and there's also the decoder down
here as
well. So this is the architecture. It's
relevant to print the architecture
because actually we're not going to
train all of these parameters. We're
just going to train a subset. We're
going to focus on the linear layers and
actually we're not even going to train
all of the parameters in the linear
layers. We're going to train adapters
that plug on. So that's going to save
memory and also make the training
faster. So you'll just take note of some
of these modules here. These are the
attention modules that we're going to
train. These are the linear layers.
We're going to train these as well.
Okay. Okay, so that's the model printed
out and we're ready now to apply those
adapters I just mentioned. So apply
little adapters to train and apply them
to these modules here. I'm going to come
back though before I apply this because
I'm going to skip Rudder because I want
to see how the base model is performing
without any fine-tuning. So we're going
to skip the data preparation just for
now. We're going to skip the training
and we're going to run straight to
inference just to hear what some of
these sounds are like.
So,
um, yeah, let's start off and just pass
in a piece of text here saying we just
finished fine-tuning a text to speech
model. We didn't finish because we're
just starting, but let's run this here
and see um, what it sounds like. There's
an alternative way of running here.
Basically, here we're using a chat
template to apply to text that we're
passing in. Whereas here we're preparing
uh the tensors in a more raw format just
by passing in um the speaker ID and text
here. So essentially we're bypassing the
chat template whereas here we're using
the chat template. Just two different
ways to call the model. So this is just
a basic called zeroot inference. You're
passing in text. You get out audio.
You're going to get a random speaker's
voice here because uh the temperature is
non zero. So you could get female, you
could get male, you could get deep, you
could get high pitched. uh you could
really get any speaker and one way you
can avoid that is by doing what's called
voice cloning. So with voice cloning
which is different to fine-tuning. With
voice cloning we will pass in a sample
and we will then get the model uh to
speak. So basically we pass in audio and
then we get the model to generate audio
and the model will tend to generate
audio that sounds more like the audio we
passed in. This is called voice cloning.
And we're just going to use some of the
data set that we already created for
this purpose. And yeah, that data set
will get passed in. And then we will ask
the model to speak this text here. And
this should be quite a bit closer to my
voice than the first example because
we've passed in a sample. Uh but it
still won't be as close as we get after
fine-tuning. Now, to be able to run
this, I do need to have loaded the data
set. So, I need to load the raw data
set. Uh, so for that, I'm actually going
to go up here to the fine-tuning. I've
got on uh data prep. I'm not going to
Yeah. And then I do need to run the
loading here. So, I will just run the
data preparation script here so that I
load in my raw data set from my YouTube
TTS. Just a note that when we load the
data set, we do need to have a data set
with an audio column and a text column.
Optionally, you can have a source column
and the source would refer to the
speaker number which would start at
zero. So, if you have two speakers, it
could be zero and then it could be one
for a different speaker. Um, if you
don't have a speaker column, what this
code here is doing is simply assigning
uh speaker zero. So, it will just uh if
there's no speaker found, it will use
the default of source which is zero. So,
it will apply a column effectively of
source being equal to zero. Okay. So,
I'm just loading the data set
here because we need to have some data
if we're going to clone. And yeah, the
message is showing here that the speaker
is being set to zero for each of the
rows, which is good cuz it's a video
where I just have one speaker. And now
it's just checking the maximum audio
length, which we're going to need when
we set up the trainer later. So, we
configure the trainer to also have uh
that maximum audio length. But while
that's running, uh, we can just go down
so that we're ready to run the cloning
script. And this is just going to run
inference with
cloning. And I do have an issue here. I
need to comment that out. And the
cloning is now underway. So, we're
basically going to pass in that well, a
sample of my voice. And then we're going
to try and generate text uh to say this
right here. So, in the meantime, I've
already generated um a sample without
the cloning. So, let's just play that.
We just finished by tuning text to
speech model.
Okay. So, yeah, you can hear it's um
it's a woman's voice. Um and as I said,
it can be unpredictable exactly what
voice you get based on temperature. And
here's another sample.
Sesame is a super cool TTS model which
can be fine-tuned with an SLO. So yeah,
you can see that there's a very wide
variance in the type of speaker that
you're going to get if you just do zero
shot
inference. I have got a sound file now
of the clone audio. Is a super cool TTS.
And here's that audio model which can be
fine- tuned with. And here's that audio.
Sesame is a super cool
TTS model which can be fine- tuned with
once.
So, it's not too bad. My voice has quite
a bit of drag on it. Sesame is a super
cool
TTS model which can be fine tuned on
slots. Sesame is a So, it's definitely
closer to my voice, but not as good as
we can get with finetuning. So, what
we're going to do now is go back up to
the start uh and we'll continue on after
having loaded the model to apply Laura
adapters and then run through the
training and we'll see if the fine-tuned
model performs better than just using
cloning on its own. So, I'm going to
scroll back up here to the point where
we loaded the
model. The model is uh is still loaded.
Um I'll just rerun this to kind of make
it more compact. And now we're going to
apply those adapters. So, we're going to
target the linear layers, the
QVO, and then also the MLP linear layers
here, gate up and down. We'll use a
lower alpha of 16. It's a pretty small
model. I usually recommend 16 if the if
it's about 1 billion in size and we will
use uh rescale Laura. This means that
the learning rate for the Laura adapters
will be scaled according to the size of
the adapters because if you have larger
adapters you need to train them more
slowly and vice
versa. So we'll go ahead with this.
We'll use a rank of 32. That means um
the rank kind of like the width or the
the height of the adapter
matrices. You can make that larger if
you want more granularity, but 32 should
be fine. And with that, we will apply
the adapters and we should get a print
out of the number of trainable
parameters. So yeah, I think we've
already applied everything there. Um,
it's not actually showing us the
trainable parameters, but we could
probably do that by just running print
trainable params. And yeah, so print
vinable parameters. You can see that
we've got about just under 2% of the
parameters are trainable. Technically,
you could train more parameters say by
training the embeddings. If you want to
do that, you would add in here modules
uh modules to
save. And the ones that you typically
would want to save or that you would
typically want to train are LM head and
lm embed or embed tokens. But um because
we're not changing the embeddings, we're
not changing the tokens here, there's
not really any reason to train them. So
just applying adapters to the linear
layers uh should be plenty. Okay, so we
have the adapters applied and we're
ready to move to training. We've already
loaded the data set uh the raw data set.
We've set the source to zero because
we've just got one speaker. There's a
little more formatting we need to do
though. And for that formatting,
basically preparing the data for the
trainer, we do need to know the maximum
audio length. We've already got that
printed here. It's about 700,000
um audio steps.
uh audio uh tokens in length. Sorry, not
tokens, but it's the length uh of the
audio. Then we need to measure the
length of the text. So, I'll just run
that cell here. And the max is uh 587.
And we're going to pass that max text
length and the max audio length into the
trainer down here. So, you can see when
we're preparing the inputs, we need to
prepare text keyword arguments and we
need to prepare audio keyword arguments.
uh we need to set a sampling rate and we
do need to set the text length and the
audio length right here. So I've got
this set and Unsloth is doing the work
to prepare the input ids, the attention
mask, the labels, the input values and
the cutoffs. So all this is uh set up
nicely for us per the original unsloth
notebook and we just need to apply this
mapping now uh to our pre-processed
examples to get a processed data set. So
I'll go ahead and do that now and then
I'll be able to print out the data set
which will show the number of rows uh
the input ids and uh these other columns
here. Next we're ready to train the
model. So we can pass that process data
set uh into the
trainer. You can see that's being passed
in here. The model is being passed in
here. We've already applied the
adapters. We will use um a virtual batch
size of eight. You probably can go a bit
bigger within the T4. Um I usually would
like to have this of 32 in size. So the
product being 32, but we don't have that
much data. So we won't go with that
large of a virtual size. We'll go with
eight with 41 rows. So it'll be uh five
different steps for every epoch of
training. We'll just train for one
epoch. Um the warm-up steps of three.
This means that we're going to increase
the learning rate slowly. To be honest,
three is a bit much if there's only five
uh in terms of total steps. So you could
just reduce that to one. Maybe the
learning rate 2EUS 4 is probably good
for a 1 billion parameter model. This
will automatically decide whether to use
float 16 or brain float 16 depending on
the TPU that's being used. Uh we'll use
Atomw 8bit optimizer to reduce memory
requirements a little bit. Uh weight
decay prevents overfitting probably not
essential. We will train at a constant
learning
rate and we will save our outputs here
uh to the output directory. So with that
I think we can uh set up training check
our current memory stats. So we've got
almost 15 GB in the GPU and nearly seven
of them are used up and we can start our
training and it's going to take about uh
10 minutes if you run the training and
what you'll find is during that training
uh the loss will fall from roughly 6.34
uh down to you know somewhere around
3.7. It looks like the loss is still
falling. So, probably there's potential
for improvement here uh in terms of the
quality of the outputs. Um maybe it'll
help a little that I reduced the number
of warm-up steps because that means
we'll have a bit higher of a learning
rate. So, I'd expect if I run this now,
I probably should uh do a little bit
better. Let's get the training going.
And when the training is done, we'll
print out the final training stats. You
can see with that batch size that I
specified, the virtual size of eight or
the actual batch of two, there's only
half of the memory being used. So you
probably could increase up to a batch
size of four without a problem. So I
would run this and then what we'll do is
run the inference again. Uh but this
time on the fine-tuned model and see how
the performance compares. And what we'll
do um what will happen automatically is
we will get saving of some of these um
of some of these sound files. So we'll
be able to just play back the zeroot
example here. We've got the zeroot audio
and the cloned audio on the base model.
But now we're going to generate uh voice
samples using the fine-tuned model. So
I'll just run this here. run all of
these cells so that when the training is
done and then run the uh cloning test
for when the training is done, training
should be underway here. Now, if I
scroll up, you can see we're at two out
of 60 steps. Note that there's no eval
data set. Ideally, you would split your
training set into train and eval. And
you would inspect the eval loss and make
sure that that's falling. If it stops
falling, that means you probably need to
stop training. either you've gone too
far in epochs or maybe your learning
rate is too high. You also typically
want to monitor the gradorm. Make sure
it's around one or less than one. You
would do that typically by adding in
here uh tensorboard. So you would report
to tensorboard. You also need to set a
log directory. So I think it's logging
deer that you need to set here. Dear
typically you would set it something
like
logs. Uh but I'm going to leave this
because we're just looking at a basic
setup for now. But if you do that, you
can pip install tensorboard and then you
can look up uh how to monitor the
losses. You can see that in a longer
video I already published. I'll probably
publish a more detailed video after this
uh too on the you on the trellis
research YouTube channel. So training is
going on. It looks like our loss is
falling which is good. And while that's
happening I'll just explain once uh the
training and the inference is done you
have the option to save the model and
also push it to hub. If you just run
this cell here, it's going to save a
copy of the model locally. So, it'll be
in your temporary storage on Collab. If
you want to push it to hub, you need to
set one of these to true. Uh both of
them to true cuz you need the model and
processor. This will just push the Laura
adapters uh which is lightweight. It'll
be a smaller repo. But if you want to
push the full model, uh you need to
merge it first. And that's where uh this
comes into play here. You can save the
model in merged form. Um well this is
just saving again in as lower adapters
but if you want to merge it to 16 bit
format you can set these two to true and
you can save the model and also push it
to hub and I believe these will actually
save both the model and the processor as
well. So if you want to push to hub yeah
you just set this one uh here true. It
will merge the model and then push it up
to hub. By the way, if you do want to
reload um a model that you have
previously created, you would do that
right back up here where we loaded the
model. Instead of specifying the base
model name, you would specify the um the
fine-tuned model name, which in my case
is going to be trellis my YouTube tts.
Okay, so training is done. We've gotten
down to 3.72 as loss and used just under
half of the memory available. Next, uh
we'll run inference using this
fine-tuned model. So actually this is
run. We should have a sample here. Uh we
should have a second sample here which
we listen to now. And then we have a
cloned example which we expect uh should
be the best. So let's give a listen to
the fine-tuned model here. We just
finished fine-tuning. Let's have a
listen. We just finished
fine-tuning a text to speech model. It's
pretty good.
So it sounds a little bit like me, but
um yeah, definitely it's a male voice.
So that randomness of it being any kind
of voice has been removed and it does
sound a little bit Irish. You can see
the pacing is not quite right. That
perhaps would be improved by better
filtering the original data set so that
I don't have segments from my YouTube
video where there's just a lot of pause.
Now there isn't a lot of pause anyway in
my YouTube videos typically cuz I cut
those out. But you could better do some
filtering on the data if you want to
improve that. Let's see a second sample
though because there is some randomness.
Sesame is a super cool TTS model which
can be tuned on Slack. So it's a little
bit of an Irish accent. Probably
indicates more data is needed to improve
the quality here. The T in tuned is
still a little bit American, although
it's kind of slightly Irish. So some
room for improvement here. But what we
see now is probably the best chance we
have, which is using the cloning plus
the fine tuning. So I'll play this
sample now. Sesame is a super cool TTS
model which can't be fine-tuned with
onslaught. Okay, so that was great. It
even has the Irish uh tuned. It even
kind of makes this little bit of an
error here which actually sounds
natural. Let's give it one more listen.
Sesame is a super cool TTS which can't
be fine tuned with on staff. Yeah. Now
maybe the super cool that's not
something I would say. So maybe it
hasn't got my ton uh my intonation
correct. But broadly speaking, this uh
this sounds pretty
great. So at this point, we've pretty
much finished the workshop. At you
should have a sound ideally with the
cloning that sounds something more like
what you do or what the person in the
video you chose sounds like. If you
wish, um you could create more data. Aim
for maybe 500 rows of 30 seconds, and I
think you would see better performance,
particularly without the voice cloning.
But you can see here that if you combine
fine-tuning with cloning, you're able to
get pretty good performance even with a
relatively small amount of data. Uh just
say I think a video of 30 minutes was
enough in this case here. So that rounds
up the workshop. As I said at the start,
you can get all of the resources on
GitHub. That's uh trellis
research/iorldsfair 2025. I will
probably make uh I will make future
videos on voice that you can check out
on the Trellis YouTube channel. probably
some more detailed videos covering in
depth a little more depth the data
preparation and some of the
hyperparameters around the finetuning
itself. Uh in the meantime let me know
if you have any questions by dropping
some of your questions or comments below
in the YouTube comments. Cheers folks.